Alright, so hopefully you used some tools to make that a little bit simpler for
you. If we load up the developer tools here, we can see that we've already got a
syntax error. And if we go over, and click right here on line 28, and it'll take
us right to where the offending error is. You can see that it actually doesn't
technically take us to the error. It takes us to the line after. Sometimes these kinds of tools
will get you close and then you'll have to figure it out from there.
So, the problem is right here: you see that local user ID
colon -1 doesn't have a comma after it, it just ends and since it was
expecting a comma, well Javascript inserts a semicolon, and that causes issues.
So let's go ahead and fix that one. Okay.
So if we insert that comma there, and then reload the page, we get our next
syntax error at line 103 and the error here is that functions expect
parenthesis after them where the perameters are. Even if it doesn't take any
perameters it still expects parenthesis here. Let's go ahead and add those in.
And again reload the page. And we get to our next error. And this one is way
down on line 207. Now this is maybe a little bit harder to see, but the problem
is right here, "this:currentTick" should have a dot, as see down here, rather
than a colon, since we use dots to access member methods and variables. Okay, so
now that we've fixed this here, and then reload, we get to another error on 318.
And here we can see on line 318 that we have a comma here, where normally we
would use a colon to specify a member method. So, if we fix that and then reload
the page, we can see that we don't have any syntax errors left. And, those are
the only ones that we put in. So, you can see that it was a lot easier to go
through the developer tools and fix these things as necessary, as it pointed it
out to us, rather than trying to walk through the code line-by-line manually.
So, I hope that shows how useful it is to have the proper tools on hand.